Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle nach einer kleinen Sommerpause zu einer ganz neuen Ausgabe, wo es hier wiederum gehen soll. Um spannende Themen rund um die Raumfahrt und für die heutige Ausgabe haben wir uns ein Thema ausgedacht, was hier so bisher nur am Rande gestreift wurde, aber nicht weniger interessant sein sollte für alle, die sich mit Raumfahrt auseinandersetzen. Und zwar geht es konkret um die Raumfahrtmedizin. Die medizinischen Aspekte der Raumfahrt, die sind ja nicht ganz unerheblich, wie man sich vorstellen kann, wenn man sich sozusagen als Mensch außerhalb seines normalen Habitats bewegt. Ja, und dazu bin ich heute nach Köln gefahren, auf den Hauptstandort des DLR und ins Institut für Luft- und Raumfahrtmedizin und begrüße Institutsleiter Prof. Dr. Robert Gerzer. Ja, Institutsleiter, ich hab's schon erwähnt. Wird man ja nicht so von heute auf morgen vielleicht mal so zum Einstieg, welchen Weg haben Sie denn so genommen, um in diesen Raumfahrtbereich zu landen?
Ja, ich hab zunächst Medizin studiert, Institut für Luft- und Raumfahrtmedizin, muss man ja Medizin können.
Ja.
In München, dann war ich...
Aber dafür gibt es einen speziellen Studiengang schon?
Nein, für die Raumfahrtmedizin.
Gibt es nicht.
Raumfahrtmedizin ist ein großes Nischenfach. Es gibt nur ein solches Institut in Deutschland, sowieso vielleicht in Europa noch. Meinen Institut gibt es ein Institut für Raumfahrtmedizin in Moskau, dann gibt es eins in Houston, dann gibt es eins in Peking und dann noch ein paar andere Institute. Die großen Raumfahrtmedizin sind dünn gesät in der Welt.
Ja, glaube ich.
Also zurück, ich habe also Medizin studiert. In München war dann in der Forschung, in der Grundlagenforschung in Heidelberg drei Jahre, dann war ich drei Jahre in der Forschung in Nashville, in Tennessee, hatte aber damit Raumfahrt überhaupt nichts am Hut. Dann war ich wieder in München, habe dann innere Medizin gemacht für sechs Jahre und habe da aber meine Forschung mit der Medizin halt verknüpft. Viel an Patienten geforscht und so ein ganz kleines bisschen an Astronauten geforscht, weil wir ein paar wissenschaftliche Fragen hatten, die wir eigentlich nur in Schwerelosigkeit klären können oder dachten, das können wir in Schwerelosigkeit klären. Und dann bin ich irgendwann gefragt worden, ob ich das Institut leiten will.
Was sind das für Sachen, die man nur in Schwerelosigkeit klären kann?
Ja, wenn wir eine einzelne Körperfunktion untersuchen, dann ist ja immer die Schwerelosigkeit, die die Funktion beeinflusst. Und beeinflusst sie nicht nur direkt, sondern auch indirekt. Also die Schwerkraft. Die Schwerkraft, habe ich Schwerelosigkeit gesagt. Die Schwerkraft. Zum Beispiel wird immer das Blut und die Körperflüssigkeit nach unten gedrückt. Nach unten bedeutet, wenn wir stehen, also in die Richtung Groß C, wenn wir liegen, in Richtung Rücken und so weiter. Das wird immer irgendwo hingedrückt. Und wie der Körper selber so allgemein ohne äußere Beeinflussung, so zum Beispiel seinen Flüssigkeitshaushalt reguliert, das ist immer schwierig.
Also man weiß nicht, ob es von alleine runterfließen würde?
Man muss immer sagen, ja, das ist unter der Bedingung, wenn ich sitze, das ist unter Bedingungen, wenn ich stehe. Aber es gibt keine absolute Position. Und da gibt es halt so ein paar Fragen, wo ich da gesagt habe, in Schwerlosigkeit könnte ich eigentlich die absolute Regulation da quasi rausfinden. Und die Schwerkraft, die beeinflusst das dann ja hinterher nur. Da hatten wir so ein paar Hypothesen und haben beim Astronauten halt geforscht. Sind ganz spannende Dinge rausgekommen, spannende Dinge, die auch so für die Klinik auch ihre Bedeutung haben. Oh, das war in den 80er, 90er, Anfang 90er Jahren, schon 20 Jahre zurück. Und die Raumfahrt war für mich eigentlich... Ich war also nicht begeistert, weil das so toll von der Technik her ist oder weil ich diese ganzen Filme gesehen hätte, sondern weil ich Wissenschaftler bin. Und da haben wir also gute spannende Fragen geklärt und wie ich dann gefragt worden bin, ob ich das tut, leiten will, habe ich gedacht, naja, schränkst dich ein. Nur mehr Raumfahrt ist ja eher eine Einschränkung. Aber andererseits, der Wissenschaftler sagt natürlich, ich kann immer noch den ganzen Menschen beforschen, aber habe die Möglichkeit, mehr Fragen zu klären, nämlich die absolute Schwerelosigkeit. Dann habe ich das gemacht. Und deshalb bin ich jetzt hier seit fast schon 20 Jahren.
Also nicht bereut den Wechsel?
Ich habe es nicht bereut, ne. Das ist ein natürlich spannendes Gebiet und es ist ein typisches Gebiet, wo man an der Grenze ist. Also ein Pioniergebiet. Pioniergebiete werden ja immer wieder in Frage gestellt. Das sagt, morgen geht es nicht mehr weiter und so weiter.
Ist ja nicht schon alles erfunden.
Ist nicht alles schon erfunden und so weiter. Das ist sehr schön.
Können Sie nicht bestätigen, dass schon alles erfunden und erforscht wäre? Das heißt, dieses Institut ist auch ein Forschungsort. Hier wird im Wesentlichen geforscht.
Hier wird im Wesentlichen geforscht. Wir machen auch, wir das nennen, operationelle Arbeit, operationelle Tätigkeit. Zum Beispiel betreuen wir die europäischen Astronauten medizinisch. Zusammen mit der ESA sind wir die Hausärzte für die Astronauten und betreuen die medizinisch.
Das Ausbildungszentrum ist hier auch gerade in Blickweite.
Das können die Hörer jetzt nicht sehen, aber das sind ungefähr 150 Meter. Wir sehen das, wenn wir hier zum Fenster rausgucken. Die Astronauten haben nicht weit zu mir ins Institut und da haben wir eine Flieger-Untersuchungsstelle und da betreuen wir die Astronauten. Oder wir betreuen Wissenschaftler, wenn auf der Raumstation ein biologisches Experiment gemacht wird. Dann gibt es da so eine Anlage, so eine Art Forschungsroboter, kann man das fast nennen. Wenn da was pipettiert werden muss, machen das nicht die Astronauten, sondern das macht dieser Roboter und der wird von unten gesteuert und das machen wir auch dann. Insofern sind das Operationelltätigkeiten, aber ansonsten machen wir im Wesentlichen Forschung.
Woran forscht man denn dann so? Ich meine, ist das dann immer wieder dieselbe Frage? Körper ist in Schwerelosigkeit und wie funktioniert er dann?
Wir machen zum Beispiel sehr viel sogenannte Bettruhe-Studien. Also der Astronaut hat ja das Problem in Schwerelosigkeit, dass er eben immer herumschwebt, was zwar schön ist für ihn, aber der menschliche Körper, der sagt, wenn ich eine Funktion nicht brauche, dann baue ich die ab. Also wenn ich den Knochen zum Stehen nicht brauche, baue ich Knochen ab. Wenn ich den Muskel zum, auch zum Stehen, zum Laufen nicht brauche, baue ich den Muskel ab. Wenn ich Herz-Kreislauf-Reflexe nicht brauche zum Stehen, dann baue ich die Reflexe ab und so weiter. Das heißt, wir haben eine hervorragende Möglichkeit, diese ganzen Reflexmechanismen zu kennen und die Anpassungsmechanismen zu können. Auf der Erde ist es so, da kriegt man niemanden zum Schweben, aber wenn wir jemanden über längere Zeit ins Bett legen, dann fängt auch der Knochen an abzubauen, die Muskeln abzubauen und so weiter. Das heißt, die Bettruhe ist so eine analoge Situation zur Raumfahrt. Wenn man jetzt sagt, naja, da braucht man ja die Raumfahrt nicht, dann legen doch gleich die Leute nur ins Bett. Es ist interessanterweise so, dass solche Studien in Bettruhe niemand macht, weil den Gesunden legen wir nicht ins Bett und legen wir nicht für Wochen und Monate ins Bett. Aber wir können wunderschön beim Gesunden, wenn wir den länger ins Bett legen, sehen, wie ist der physiologische Anpassungsmechanismus von Knochen, von Muskeln und von vielen Körpersystemen und natürlich wieder das Umgekehrte. Wie gewöhnt man sich wieder an die Schwerkraft? Also wir haben zum Beispiel das Problem, es gibt ja viele Patienten, es gibt leider viele Patienten, die auch lange im Bett liegen. Diese Problematik der Gesundheitsprobleme, die alleine durch das lange im Bett liegen erzeugt werden, haben wir eigentlich noch gar nicht richtig verstanden, merken wir. Und deshalb sind wir jetzt plötzlich mit Leuten zusammen, die...
Also wir im Sinne von die gesamte Medizin.
Die Medizin, wir heißt die Medizin, nicht bloß mein Institut, sondern die Medizin. Und deshalb machen wir viele Bettruhe- Studien. Und die Bettruhe-Studien, da werden typischerweise auch die Leute so ein bisschen mit Kopf-Tieflage gelegt, weil wir natürlich analog Situation zur Schwierlosigkeit wollen. In Kopf-Tieflage, wenn der Körper so ein bisschen nach unten mit 6 Grad nach unten geneigt ist, dann wird die Flüssigkeitssäule im Körper, die Flüssigkeit so ein bisschen in Richtung Kopf geschoben. Und das ist was Ähnliches in Schwierlosigkeit, weil in Schwierlosigkeit die Spierkraft nicht mehr die Flüssigkeit nach unten zieht. Und deshalb ist mehr Flüssigkeit eher weit oben in der oberen Körperhilfe.
Weil der Körper halt so gebaut ist, alles nach oben zu pumpen.
Und dann forschen wir halt zum einen rein wissenschaftlich, was diese Mechanismen sind, die dazu führen, dass sich Körpersysteme ändern. Was uns natürlich vor allem interessiert, wie können wir diese Veränderung verhindern? Also quasi, wie können wir, wenn wir den Bettlägering anschauen, wie können wir, während jemand im Bett liegt, verhindern, dass er die negativen Effekte des Im-Bett-Liegens kriegt? Bei Mastonauten ist die Frage, wie können wir den halt so gesund halten, dass der, wenn er wieder landet, eben nicht plötzlich Osteoporose hat oder dass er nicht so Herz-Kreislauf-instabil ist, dass er öfter mal umfällt, dass er mal umkippt. Das sind ja operationelle Fragen. Und deshalb ist es auch so, dass unsere Forschungsfragen, die haben immer zwei Aspekte. Der eine Aspekt ist ein sogenannte operationeller Aspekt. Das heißt, wir müssen forschen, dass die Astronauten gesund sind, weil sie Astronauten sind. Das ist der eine Aspekt. Bedeutet, wenn es jetzt keine bemannte Raumfahrt gäbe, müsste man das auch nicht beforschen. Dass sie aber gibt, muss man das beforschen, damit der Astronaut gesund bleibt, ist der eine Aspekt. Der andere Aspekt ist aber der rein wissenschaftliche, der mich auch am meisten interessiert. Rein wissenschaftliche, dass ich die einzigartige Möglichkeit habe, den Menschen eben ohne den dauernden störenden Einfluss der Schwerkraft zu untersuchen.
Diese dumme Schwerkraft. Das heißt, es geht primär eigentlich auch um einen Wissensgewinn für die Medizin als solche auf diesen Planeten, was ja auch deutlich mehr Leuten relevant ist als die paar, die jetzt gerade ins All fliegen. Aber man hat einfach dieses Privileg, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir haben eigentlich permanente Möglichkeit, in irgendeiner Form etwas zu testen, weil es den Zugang zu Raumstationen gibt und zu zahlreichen anderen Missionen.
Interessanterweise sind aber die beiden Themen total verknüpft, weil wir ja nur bei solchen Themen Probleme haben, die Astronauten gut zu betreuen, wo wir eigentlich auf der Erde die Physiologie nicht verstanden haben. Wenn wir nämlich genau wüssten, wie der Körper funktioniert, dann können wir eigentlich einfach sagen, dann nehmen wir halt die Schwerkraft weg, dann muss der Körper so funktionieren und dann, wenn der Astronaut dann Knochenabbau, dann muss man das und das machen, damit er kein Knochen mehr abbaut. Das klingt also ganz einfach, diese operationellen Fragen, aber wir haben nur deshalb Schwierigkeiten, Astronauten ordentlich zu betreuen, weil wir auch die Grundlagen darunter nicht ganz verstanden haben. Insofern fließt doch wieder am Schluss alles zusammen und wir haben ein höchst wichtiges Forschungsgebiet. Da muss man jetzt spekulieren, aber wir wundern uns immer wieder, wenn wir forschen, wie viel wir doch nicht verstehen und wie viel wir dann auch annehmen, dass es stimmen würde und dann funktioniert es doch wieder anders. Also zum Beispiel hat man gesagt, okay, wir verstehen, wie der Körper die Flüssigkeit reguliert, die Flüssigkeitssäule reguliert und dann gesagt, naja, in Späherlosigkeit, wenn der Mensch späherlos ist, wird der Blut nicht mehr nach unten gedrückt, also muss vermehrt Blut im Herzen sein beim Astronauten, weil sich in der Oberkörperhälfte mehr verteilt und dann muss der Druck im Herzen ansteigen. Jetzt haben wir dann, oder Kollegen von uns Amerikaner, haben dann beim Astronauten in Späherlosigkeit richtig einen Katheter, den haben sich die Astronauten quasi selber ins Herz geschoben, im Herz den Blutdruck gemessen, den sogenannten Vorhofsdruck gemessen. Und siehe da, das was schon in Lehrbuchen drin steht, der Blutdruck steigt an im Vorhof, der war halt nicht angestiegen, der ist sogar abgesunken. Etwas, was unser Wissen, und da muss man wieder anfangen und sagen, haben wir die Physiologie verstanden? Wo haben wir was nicht verstanden? Und sowas gehört einfach zum grundsätzlichen Wissen.
Wenn ich das so höre, also wenn ich mir so vorstelle, ich wäre jetzt Astronaut und ich würde mir dann im Weltall auch noch irgendwie eine Nadel ins Herz schieben.
Nicht eine Nadel, sondern Katheter ist das. Aber ist egal.
Na ja gut, aber da ist schon was in mir drin. Gut, ist schon in der Raumzeitausgabe Nummer 11 im Gespräch mit Samantha und Christopher Reddy ist mir klar geworden, dass die Leute, die sich für diesen Beruf entschieden haben, sowieso die härtesten sind, aber davon abgesehen, solche Experimente erfordern natürlich auch eine sehr, also mehr als sonst noch das Verhältnis zwischen Patient und Arzt, so ein Vertrauensverhältnis. Insofern, denke ich, spielt die Psychologie an der Stelle auch eine extrem große Rolle.
Also Vertrauensverhältnis ist wahnsinnig wichtig. Die Astronauten sind ja da oben alleine und man kann nicht immer überprüfen, was die machen. Das heißt, wenn der nicht das tut, was man versprochen hat, dann wären wir aufgeschmissen. Deshalb ist das Vertrauensverhältnis essentiell, dass es gut ist. Also die Astronauten, die werden geschult im Training. Zum einen werden sie medizinisch geschult, kriegen medizinische Vorlesungen. Auch Astronauten, die keine Mediziner sind, damit sie eine Ahnung über den Körper haben. Dann werden ihnen auch die einzelnen Experimente so beigebracht, dass man versucht, dass sie wirklich die wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen dahinter auch verstehen. Und die sind ja auch ausgewählte Leute, so dass die durchaus in der Lage sind, die Experimente, auch wenn sie keine Mediziner sind, hervorragend zu verstehen. Und man versucht auch, die so zu gewinnen, dass die die Experimente quasi sich ein bisschen zu eigen machen. Das ist auch bei medizinischen Experimenten immer so, dass die Astronauten nicht eingeteilt werden. Du musst das und das und das machen, du musst dir die und jenen Nadel reinstechen, sag ich jetzt mal, um bei ihnen zu bleiben. Sondern es werden die Experimente erklärt und die Astronauten dürfen sich selber melden bei medizinischen Experimenten. Die dürfen sagen, okay, ich mach dieses oder jenes Experiment, weil ich auch die wissenschaftliche Frage dahinter spannend halte.
Ah, verstehe.
So haben wir zum Beispiel im Augenblick ein Experiment, das läuft schon seit vier oder fünf Jahren. Da haben sich zu unserer großen Freude acht Astronauten bereit erklärt, das mitzumachen. Wir haben inzwischen, ich glaube sechs sind abgeschlossen, also sechs Experimente sind abgeschlossen, seit den letzten drei Jahren und auf zwei warten wir noch. Wir haben also inzwischen fast alle durch und die Astronauten machen das auch immer und hoffen natürlich selber, dass spannende Sachen rauskommen. Und insofern ist dieses Vertrauensverhältnis und die Psychologie, wie sie sagen, extrem wichtig.
Ist denn die Psychologie als solche auch hier ein Thema?
Die Psychologie in der Raumfahrt ist natürlich wahnsinnig wichtig. Je länger die Astronauten da oben bleiben, desto wichtiger ist es. Wir überlegen jetzt schon, wie das aussehen würde, wenn die mal zum Mars fliegen und dann ein paar Jahre dann weg sind. Wenn man zum Mars fliegt, ist ja so, dass die Erde dann teilweise auf der anderen Seite der Sonne ist. Also man sieht da nicht mehr zur Erde runter, wenn man da in Richtung Mars unterwegs ist.
Auch ohne Funkkontakt?
Funkkontakt ist eine Verzögerung in einer Richtung, 20 Minuten. Da macht man sich die Sorgen, dass man sagt, na ja, wahrscheinlich wird die Psychologie da die größte Herausforderung sein. Sind die normalen medizinischen Fragen wahrscheinlich nicht so wichtig? Kriegt eine Depression, Streiten, die gibt es Handkämpfe und so weiter. Es sind ja lauter Menschen, die da zusammenleben müssen.
Also es gibt hier auch eine Unterabteilung, die sich mit Psychologie auseinandersetzt. Das war eigentlich so meine Frage jetzt hier beim Institut.
Wir haben hier eine Abteilung Psychologie. Von der Abteilung Psychologie arbeiten auch Mitarbeiter mit Astronauten, mit den Problemen der Psychologie in der Raumfahrt. Ansonsten machen wir da sehr viel Luftfahrt. Wir machen sehr viel Auswahl von fliegenden Personal für Fluggesellschaften.
Also Luftfahrt ist natürlich hier auch ein Thema, auch wenn wir uns jetzt hier im Gespräch auf die Raumfahrt konzentrieren. Inwiefern sind Sie denn ein permanenter Begleiter, also wenn jetzt eine neue Mission gestartet wird und die meine ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, die gesamte Raumfahrtenmedizin, egal ob sie jetzt in Russland oder Europa oder USA angesiedelt ist. Ich denke, bei dem einen Projekt ist man mal mehr, mal weniger eingebunden, weil es ja auch viel Kooperation gibt mit den anderen Raumfahrtgesellschaften. Wenn jetzt so ein Start ansteht, an dem Astronauten teilnehmen, sagen wir mal, neue Crew fliegt zur ISS, das ist ja derzeit eigentlich das gängigste, an welcher Stelle beginnt denn da die Kooperation? Wann ist das erste Mal, dass die Medizin gefragt ist?
Also wenn Astronauten fliegen, ist immer ein Mediziner dabei, also nicht nicht im Raumschiff, sondern im Kontrollzentrum. Also schon im Training muss immer alles mit Medizin begleitet werden. Wenn jetzt in Houston, also nicht in Amerika, mit dem Shuttle, ein Astronaut geflogen ist, muss man inzwischen sagen, dann ist schon beim Training schon ein oder zwei Ärzte dabei, die werden dann in das Team in Houston, im Kontrollzentrum implementiert. Die arbeiten dann an den Schichten mit, die die Astronauten betreuen. Wenn unser Astronaut oder unsere Astronautin dann fliegt, dann fährt dann ein Crew Searcher, wie wir die nennen, fährt damit nach Florida, ist in der ganzen Zeit in Florida dabei, bis der Astronaut einsteigt. Und wenn er dann losgeflogen ist, fliegt der Arzt nach Houston und setzt sich in den Kontrollraum und passt mit auf. Er passt aber jetzt nicht nur auf einen europäischen Astronauten auf, sondern ist dann in dem Team der Ärzte, die Schichtbetrieb machen, um über 24 Stunden dann die Astronauten zu betreuen. Die Aufgabe der Ärzte ist dann dabei, in der Regel nicht dauernd gucken, was hat der für einen Blutdruck, oder dauernd Telemedizin zu machen, sondern die Aufgabe ist, erstmal zu gucken, in dem Team ist in der Raumstation genügend Druck, ist genügend Sauerstoff, ist irgendwas Toxisches, also das sogenannte Lebenserhaltungssystem zu überwachen und dann gibt es natürlich tägliche Möglichkeit von einem täglichen vertrauensvollen Gespräch nur zwischen Arzt und Astronaut. Ein tägliches medizinisches Briefing und ansonsten ist natürlich, wenn es Probleme gibt, dann ist der Arzt gefragt, dann Ratschläge zu geben, entweder was nimmt man jetzt für Tablettchen, wenn es ein kleines Problem gibt oder dann auch irgendeine Untersuchung zu, Ultraschalluntersuchung kann man da zum Beispiel machen, eine Untersuchung anzuleiern, dass die gemacht wird. Im schlimmsten Fall könnte natürlich auch ein Astronaut mal runterholen beziehungsweise wenn einer schwer krank würde, was so noch nicht passiert ist, dann müsste eine Kapsel runterfliegen, das ist so, auf der Raumstation sind zurzeit sechs Leute und zwei Soyuzkapseln, die im Notfall abdocken könnten, sodass pro Soyuzkapsel also drei Leute, sodass alle sechs evakuiert werden. Wenn also einer krank würde und runter müsste, dann müssten drei Leute runter, damit das Notfall noch da ist.
Sie sagten jetzt, das fängt schon mit dem Training an. Wann fängt das an, vor dem Start? Reden wir jetzt von Wochen oder Monaten oder?
Ja, es gibt spezifisches Training. Es ist eigentlich normalerweise bis zu zwei Jahren. Wenn jemand ausgesucht wird für eine Mission, dann kommt drauf an, wie komplex die Mission ist, wie komplex die Aufgabe ist. Aber so ein bis zwei Jahre müssen die trainieren und dann muss immer, wenn es natürlich nur Schulunterricht ist, dann braucht der Arzt nicht dabei sein. Aber wenn die Fallschirmspringen oder wenn die irgendwas machen, wo unter Umständen der Arzt benötigt wird, dann muss halt der Arzt immer mit. Bedeutet für unsere Ärzte, dass die relativ viel reisen müssen. Weil so eine Crew, die wird jetzt ausgewählt, um an einem, um auf der Raumstation zu arbeiten. Und in der Raumstation gibt es verschiedene Module, gibt es ein mekanisches Modul, Forschungsmodul. Das mekanische Forschungsmodul trainiert man in Amerika. Dann gibt es das europäische Modul, das Columbus-Modul, das trainiert man hier im Europäischen Astronautentrainingszentrum. Dann fliegt für das Training in dem Columbus-Modul die gesamte Crew, die dann hochfliegen wird, also alle drei Astronauten, wenn die jetzt im Soyuz fliegen, die kommen dann und trainieren hier. Dann gibt es Arbeiten im Kibo-Modul. Kibo ist japanisches Modul. Da müssen die nach Japan. Und bei solchen Trainings müssen dann unsere Crew-Searchants auch mitfliegen. Und dann ist es typischerweise so, vor dem Start, die letzten paar Monate, ist das Training konzentriert auf Houston. Beziehungsweise dann fliegen die rüber nach Florida, nach Cape Kennedy, sodass dann unsere Ärzte vor dem Flug zwei Monate, drei Monate dann in Houston sitzen. Also das ist eine massive Belastung für Reisetätigkeit, Belastung für die Ärzte, die diesen Job machen. Wir haben derzeit von unserem Institut zwei Ärzte abgestellt an die ESA, die das machen und ich ziehe immer den Hut vor denen, weil die natürlich, wenn am 3. Januar so ein Shuttle fliegt oder so eine Rackete fliegt, über Weihnachten dann in Florida sitzen und die Familie zu Hause hier oder in Moskau oder im Baikonur sitzen und dann immer monatelang unterwegs sind. Es macht ihnen natürlich Spaß, die Aufgabe, aber es kann schon ermüdend werden. Vor allem, wenn zum Beispiel ein Start ist, dann wird der verschoben. Sitzen die wunderschön in Florida an der Küste und warten auf den neuen Start, haben eigentlich wenig zu tun, dann sagt man wunderschönen Urlaub, aber die Familie mit den Kindern ist zu Hause, die haben mehr Probleme, wie es immer im Leben ist und dann sitzt man da in irgendeinem schönen Hotel in Florida und kann nicht aus. Also ich beneide diese Ärzte nicht, sondern finde es immer toll, dass die ihre Arbeit so gut machen.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch eine extreme Verantwortung, die man an der Stelle übernimmt, weil man ja so eigentlich der Betreuer des Astronauten ist und es hängt dann ja eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge an einem. Gibt es denn noch ein Backup für diesen Arzt?
Im Kontrollzentrum ist ja immer ein ganzes Team und die Entscheidungen macht nicht der Arzt. Also der kann natürlich Entscheidungen treffen und sagen, dieser Astronaut muss jetzt runter. Das ist dann tatsächlich eine weitreichende Entscheidung. Aber ansonsten sitzen da 20, 30 Leute. Je nachdem, welche Aktivität gerade.
Aber gerade in dieser Vorbereitungsphase wächst man ja auch psychologisch an die Personen heran.
In der Vorbereitungsphase genau wie sie sagen, psychologisch, dann kümmern sich die halt auch nicht bloß um die Medizin, sondern auch schauen, dass, wenn er gestresst ist, dass man dem hilft, dass es ihm einigermaßen gut geht. Gesundheit ist nach WHO-Definition nicht bloß das körperliche, sondern nach psychischem Wohlergehen. Und da kümmern sich genau unsere Ärzte auch immer darum, dass die Leute immer einigermaßen gute Laune haben oder dass ihnen bei irgendwelchen Problemen auch geholfen wird. Typischerweise kennen die Ärzte auch dann die Familien und sind da ein bisschen privat integriert.
Für mich klingt das jetzt so, als ob das die Ärzte, die gerade diesen Einsatz machen, also, ich meine, die müssen ja sehr universell ausgebildet sein. Ich meine, gut, jeder Arzt hat ohnehin eine universelle Ausbildung, aber man weiß es ja, man spezialisiert sich und viele Ärzte machen dann vielleicht ihr Leben lang eben nur diesen Aspekt der Medizin. An der Stelle muss man ja eigentlich extrem breitbandig aufgestellt sein. Welche Voraussetzungen müssen denn diese Ärzte an der Stelle als Begleiter erfüllen, um dafür überhaupt geeignet zu sein?
Also wie sie sagen, man muss breit aufgestellt sein, also typisch, also Vorausbildung zum Beispiel Allgemeinarzt, der von allem etwas kann und dann auch vor allem die Entscheidung treffen kann, okay, jetzt muss ein anderer ran, ist eine sehr gute Voraussetzung unter Internisten oder Leuten, die im Notfall, Notärzte, Notfallteams, Anästhesisten sind sehr gute Voraussetzungen. Um aber Crewsearchern zu sein, gibt es noch einen Kurs, da muss man dann die Ärzte für ein Jahr in die USA schicken, um dann einen speziellen Kurs zu machen, damit die Astronauten ordentlich die Astronauten betreuen können. Die lernen natürlich die ganze Raumfahrtphysiologie, aber lernen halt die Notfallmaßnahmen, die erforderlich sind. Es ist dann immer auch Teamarbeit notwendig. Wenn die Astronauten selber kriegen, auch eine Ausbildung, auch eine Ausbildung, um im Notfall helfen zu können. Und diese Ausbildung ist auch ein Mittel kompliziert. Sie können sich vorstellen, wenn jetzt ein Astronaut bewusstlos würde, man müsste ihn reanimieren, dann kann man ja nicht so die Reanimation machen, indem man eine externe Herzmassage macht. Wenn man da mit der Hand auf das Herz drückt, mit dem Arm, dann fliegt man ja weg. Man muss also lernen, den Patienten zu fixieren, sodass der nicht wegfliegt und sich selber so zu fixieren, dass man arbeiten kann. Man meint jetzt, das ist ganz einfach, aber das ist höchst kompliziert. Deshalb braucht man für solche Sachen eine eigene Schulung. Solche Schulungen macht man dann bei den Astronauten. Aber die Ärzte müssen natürlich das alles wissen. Die müssen wissen, wie das geht, sonst geben sie einen falschen Ratschlag. Und deshalb brauchen die eine eigene Schulung bezüglich der Raumfahrtmedizin. Und so ein Raumschiff ist immer sehr kompliziert, weil das ein sogenanntes geschlossenes Lebenserhaltungssystem ist. Das heißt, die Luft, die man atmet, die wird wieder rezekuliert und es werden die Giftstoffe rausgefiltert. Man muss aber immer eben aufpassen, dass da nicht irgendwie sich irgendwelche Giftstoffe ansammeln. Weil ein Filter nicht gut arbeitet oder weil irgendwo eine versteckte Giftquelle ist, die man nicht erkennt, und irgendwann reicht die Filterkapazität nicht aus. An sowas denkt man auf der Erde gar nicht. Aber die Ausbildung der Crew Searchens, die beinhaltet eben auch, was gibt es für gefährliche Stoffe in so einem Raumschiff und worauf muss man deshalb speziell achten. Also auf der Meerstation gab es so Kühlflüssigkeiten, die Probleme gemacht haben. Und da muss man natürlich wissen, dass es so Kühlflüssigkeiten gibt und man muss wissen, welche möglichen Probleme es gibt. Und umgekehrt muss man wissen, wenn jetzt jemand Kopfweh hat, und es wird immer heiß oder kalt, muss man wissen, was sind die wahrscheinlich Gründe. Das sind dann eben andere Gründe als hier auf der Erde.
Sehr vielschichtige Problematik. Vielleicht ist es auch mal ganz sinnvoll, nochmal so den Flug so nachzuvollziehen, um einfach auch mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen, wie der Körper so reagiert, wenn er so aus einem normalen Bereich herausgenommen wird. Schwerelosigkeit ist ja wahrscheinlich das wichtigste, aber auch nicht unbedingt der einzige Aspekt dabei. Ab wann, gut, ich meine mit dem Start geht es im Prinzip los, weiß nicht, die Situation so vorher in der Kapsel ist wahrscheinlich eher eine psychologische Frage, damit umzugehen. Aber was muss denn der Körper so durchmachen bei so einem Start?
Vielleicht fangen wir sogar noch vor dem Start an. Vor dem Start ist eine Woche lang Quarantäne, weil in Schwerelosigkeit das Immunsystem nicht richtig funktioniert. Die Immunzellen funktionieren nicht richtig. Wir wissen immer noch nicht, woran das liegt. Gibt es irgendeinen ganz wichtigen Immunmechanismus, der abgeschaltet wird? Und den haben wir noch nicht ganz im Griff. Da gibt es viele Forschungen.
Wo schlagartig abgeschaltet wird?
Interessanterweise auch schlagartig abgeschaltet wird.
Das heißt, Gravitation geht sozusagen gegen Null und auf einmal hört auf, irgendwas zu funktionieren oder alles?
Das Immunsystem funktioniert halt schlechter. Es kann schlechter aufgeweckt werden.
Es wird sozusagen in so einen Schlaf versetzt.
Und das passiert sofort. Sowas kann man auch, wenn man Zellen in Entspällosigkeit bringt, innerhalb von ein paar Sekunden messen. Ok, deshalb gibt es die Quarantäne. Dann gehen die ins Raumschiff und warten, bis der Start kommt. Werden angeschnallt und das kann durchaus ein paar Stunden dauern. Deshalb haben die alle kriegen die eine Windel an, damit sie da nicht wieder den Start unterbrechen müssen. Und wenn die dann losstarten, dann haben wir erstmal die Beschleunigung. Die ist in der Soyuz-Rakete bis zu 3,5 Gs. Das ist also relativ heftig. Aber es sind immer bloß Beschleunigungsspitzen beim Start, weil die im Soyuz-System mit einer Rakete starten. Und die Astronauten sagen es immer, die haben das intensiv trainiert und das belastet sie eigentlich nicht so heftig. Immer wenn eine Stufe abgefeuert wird, dann wackelt das heftig. Und dann sagen die Astronauten, das ist viel aufregender, wenn es heftig zu wackeln beginnt, als die Beschleunigung selber. Ansonsten ist man in 8 Minuten schon in Schwerelosigkeit. Das geht also relativ flott.
Aber dieser reine Druck des Starts, wie stark ist die Belastung in der Soyuz?
Der Druck des Starts, wenn Sie das mal sehen, dann hebt so eine Soyuz-Rakete erst mal ganz langsam ab, sodass die das quasi gar nicht merken. Die Beschleunigung baut sich erst mit der Zeit auf. Das ist also nicht was Schlagartiges. Die Beschleunigung spitzen. Die Beschleunigung baut sich so langsam auf innerhalb von ein, zwei Minuten. Wenn dann die erste Stufe quasi leer ist, dann hat dieser Treibstoff am meisten Beschleunigungsmöglichkeit. Und dann ist die Beschleunigung am höchsten. Dann wird die Stufe abgesprengt. Und dann geht es wieder runter auf 2 Gs und dann geht es wieder hoch auf 3,5 Gs. Und es gibt also nur drei solche Spitzen. Und die Podcast-Astronauten sagen, die Spitze habe ich so oft trainiert. Und dann kommt schlagartig die Schwerlosigkeit nach acht Minuten. Das ist ganz schnell, weil man ja bloß 300 Kilometer hoch fliegt oder 350 Kilometer. Kommt ganz schnell. Und Schwerlosigkeit herrscht übrigens nicht, weil da oben schon Schwerlosigkeit herrscht, sondern weil die mit 28.000 Stundenkilometer fliegen. Und im Flug werden sie von der Erdanziehung angezogen. Das heißt, so eine Rakete, so ein Raumschiff fällt mit 28.000 Stundenkilometer beständig um die Erde rum. Und alles, was da drin ist, ist wie beim Flugzeug, wie beim Parabel fliegt, ist dann innen drin schwerelos. Eigentlich herrscht da noch fast eine G-Beschleunigung. Also eine kleine Schummelei. Das ist nicht da oben die Schwierlosigkeit, sondern das ist die Geschwindigkeit, mit der wir rumfallen.
Aber die Gravitation wird aufgelöst, wird egalisiert?
Die wird egalisiert, weil alles gleich schnell fällt. Und damit ist man funktionell schwerelos. Und dann ist die Schwierlosigkeit. Und dann ist es leider so, dass unser Gehirn das nicht richtig geübt hat und trainiert hat. Wir haben auch im Innenohr so ein System, das sind so kleine Steinchen, die werden normalerweise runtergedrückt. Wir nennen die Otolithen. Die schweben dann natürlich auch. Und dann weiß das Hirn plötzlich nicht mehr so richtig, was ist jetzt los, wo ist jetzt oben und unten. Und dann ist bei einigen Astronauten so, dass die empfinden haben, da wo mein Kopf ist, ist oben. Die anderen, die haben dann das Empfinden, da wo ich gelernt habe, dass im Raumschiff oben ist, beim Training da ist, bei mir oben, auch wenn ich mit dem Kopf andersrum bin. Und wenn man sich schneller bewegt, den Kopf bewegt, dann sind diese, das ist das Innenohr, dann ist die Information, wird dann fehlinterpretiert und am Schluss wird es etlichen schlecht, Übelkeit kommt. Das heißt, in den ersten drei Tagen der Schwerlosigkeit ist fast jedem mehr oder weniger übel. Ein Drittel übergibt sich sogar, ein Drittel der Synoten. Und fast alle nehmen deshalb vorher Tabletten bzw. kriegen eine Spritze, die man auch kriegt, wenn man parabel fliegt. Und zum Glück ist das Ganze nach drei bis fünf Tagen vorbei. Nach fünf Tagen geht es jedem blendend. Dann sagen die, jetzt bin ich zuhause, auf der Erde ist es ganz komisch, hier schwebt alles und dann sind die angepasst.
Also wie nimmt denn der, welche Organe des Menschen spielen überhaupt eine Rolle jetzt auf der Erde, um mit der Schwerelosigkeit, nein, mit der Schwerkraft, mit der Schwerkraft klarzukommen? Ist das jetzt nur das Ohr, was dafür zuständig ist?
Also das Innenohr, das regelt, das ist wichtig, dass wir erkennen, in welcher körperlichen Lage befinden wir uns. Und das wird am ersten aufgeweckt, weil wir eben in Schwerelosigkeit sind und dann gibt es uns Fehlsignale erstmal und dann kann dem Astronauten leicht schlecht werden, das ist das Innenohr.
Aber warum wird einem schlecht?
Warum wird einem schlecht? Es gibt verschiedene Hypothesen, man weiß es noch nicht genau, warum es einem schlecht wird. Es gibt verschiedene Hypothesen. Eine Hypothese habe ich jetzt ohne die Fachworte zu nennen, zu erklären versucht. Er ist, dass diese Steinchen, die im Innenohr sind, dass die was anderes sagen letztlich als das Auge uns sagt. So dass das Innenohr und das Auge, das Auge sagt, okay, da vorne ist die Raumschiffwand, also ich bin in der und der körperlichen Position und ich bin im Stuhl, also ich bin wie auf der Erde. Das Innenohr sagt, irgendwie ich schwebe und dann gibt es auch noch das Problem, dass bei einem im Innenohr die Steinchen rechts anders schwer sind als links, also leichter oder schwerer.
Und das ist sozusagen diese Dissonanz der Wahrnehmung, die führt dann zu einer Übelkeit.
Auf der Erde wird es ausgeglichen, dass die verschiedenen schwer sind. In Schwerlosigkeit gleicht das System immer noch auf. Also dann plötzlich rechts mehr als links. Dann empfind sich der Astronaut plötzlich vom Auge her gradsitzend, vom Innenohr her irgendwie in einer Schräglage und vom Gefühl her schwebend. Und dann gibt es diesen sogenannten Mismatch, also verschiedene Informationen. Und wir haben offensichtlich eine Entwicklungsgeschichte gelernt. Wenn wir verschiedene Informationen haben, dann ist es wie bei einer Vergiftung. Und dann muss das Gift raus. Vergiftung, man isst was, das ist vergiftet, dann wird es einem schwindlig. Schwindlig werden ist unterschiedlicher Sinn und Eindruck. Und das heißt, Gift muss raus. Das heißt, der Körper meint, er ist vergiftet worden und reagiert mit der Übelkeit da oben. Aber ansonsten, ich weiß schon, beim nächsten System haben wir dann ein Herz-Kreislauf. Das dauert ein paar Tage, bis das Herz-Kreislauf-System dann anfängt. Herz-Kreislauf, wenn wir aufstehen, dann ändert sich ja der Blutdruck in unserem Körper. Weil, wenn wir liegen, dann muss das Herz ja nur Blut nach vorne schieben. Zum Kopf nach vorne, wenn wir liegen. Wenn wir jetzt den Kopf heben oder den ganzen Körper heben, dann kommt die Schwerkraft. Die zieht dann die ganze Flüssigkeitssolle nach unten. Plötzlich muss das Herz überhaupt genügend Blut kriegen, weil das Blut ja nach unten geschoben wird. Und zweitens noch Blut zum Hirn hochschieben. Das heißt, die Herzfunktion muss sich ändern beim Aufstehen und dafür haben wir Reflexe. Die Reflexe sagen dem Herzen, du musst schneller schlagen, musst stärker schlagen, sagen den Blutgefäßen. Du musst dich überall zusammenziehen, damit der Blutdruck steigt, damit noch genügend Blut nach oben kommt. Und in Schwierlosigkeit verlernt das das Herz. Sagt, das brauche ich nicht mehr, den Reflex. Dann wird der abgebaut. Wenn Astronauten später landen, dann stehen sie. Wenn sie ein paar Minuten stehen, dann gibt es viele Astronauten, die einfach nach drei, vier, fünf Minuten umkippen, weil das Herz diesen Reflex nicht mehr hat. Das ist das Herz. Dann haben wir die Muskulatur und die Knochen. Der Astronaut muss nie mehr stehen. Der ist ja als ob er da und im Bett liegen würde. Deshalb werden vor allem die Muskeln und die Knochen, die man zum Stehen und zum Laufen braucht, abgebaut. Laufen tut der auch nicht mehr. Das heißt, der Knochen, der wird nicht mehr belastet und in dem Augenblick fängt der an abzubauen.
Ist das irgendwie klar? Also wie schnell macht der Körper das? Also wie schnell ist die Reaktion auf die Schwerelosigkeit? Wann beginnt dieser Abbau?
Der Knochen- und Muskelabbau, das Muskelabbau oder Muskeländerung beginnt innerhalb von ein paar Stunden, aber der Abbau beginnt innerhalb von ein paar Tagen. Und richtig messbar wird es vielleicht nach vier, fünf Tagen bei den Muskeln. Beim Knochen ist richtig messbar der Abbau von Knochenmasse erst nach vier, minimal vier Wochen. Es geht also relativ langsam. Beim Knochen ist interessanterweise auch nicht so, dass nicht die gesamten Knochen oder auch bei Muskels gleiche, nicht alle Muskeln abgebaut werden, nicht der gesamte Knochen, sondern von dem Knochen nur die Areale, die wir zum Stehen brauchen, zum Laufen brauchen. Also zum Beispiel das Fersenbein unten wird abgebaut, die Unterschenkelknochen mehr als Oberschenkelknochen, aber wieder die Hüfte wird wieder vermehrt abgebaut, untere Wirbelsäule wieder vermehrt, obere Wirbelsäule fast gar nicht. Die Rippen, die ändern sich überhaupt nicht. Die Arme ändern sich die Knochen überhaupt nicht, weil wir auf der Erde die so wenig anstrengen, als wären wir immer in Schwerelosigkeit. Also es hängt immer davon ab, wie ist die Belastung. Deshalb ist diese Knochenabbau beim Astronaten auch ein anderer Knochenabbau als bei den älteren Leuten. Der Knochenabbau der älteren Leute ist bedingt durch hormonelle Umstellungen. Und hormonell bedeutet ganz den Körper betreffend. Deshalb ist es auch nicht so richtig vergleichbar miteinander, sondern es ist vergleichbar mit dem Knochenabbau, denn die Leute haben die dauernd im Bett liegen müssen, mit der Bettlägerigkeit.
Angenommen, das ist jetzt ein bisschen ein mobiles Beispiel, aber angenommen jemand würde überhaupt nicht mehr zurückkehren wollen oder können. Und er wäre sozusagen in dieser Situation, er würde jetzt fortan immer im Weltall leben. Und man müsste sich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht auch sorgen um irgendeine Funktion, die man auf der Erde braucht, weil die einfach nicht mehr in Frage kommt. Was würde aus diesem Menschen werden? Wie würde der sich verändern?
Der würde ziemlich ähnlich aussehen wie Leute, die eben gelähmt sind. Es gibt ja die Tetraplegiker, also Leute, die nicht stehen laufen können.
So eine Querschnitts-Schnittslähmung.
Querschnittsgelähmter auch, natürlich. Wie solche Leute dann ohne Training. Da ist es ja auch so, dass die Muskeln massiv abbauen, die Knochen massiv abbauen. Ab irgendeinem Punkt ist es dann leider nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen.
Aber man benutzt doch seine Beine noch.
Ja, das reicht nicht aus bei Massanaten. Das ist das Problem. Der benutzt sie ja nur, um sich mal irgendwo festzuhalten.
Ja gut, aber würde der Körper nicht dafür sorgen, dass diese Funktion auch immer möglich ist? Oder würde es so weit zurückgehen, dass er das dann auch nicht mehr könnte?
Da braucht man nur die Querschnittsgelähmten anschauen. Ab irgendeinem Punkt versteifen sich leider dann die Muskeln. Wenn die Muskeln nicht mehr benutzt werden, dann gibt es auch Versteifungen und Verkalkungen. Und das ist dann nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen.
Das heißt, der Körper ist einfach nicht dafür gemacht und würde sich jetzt auch nicht so anpassen, dass selbst diese minimale Dienstleistung, die die Gliedmaßen noch verrichten, auch dauerhaft erhalten bleibt?
Nach allem, was wir wissen, ist der Körper nicht dafür gemacht. Der ist dafür gemacht, beständig gegen die Schwerkraft zu kämpfen. Und diese Nullposition ohne Schwerkraft, die für diesen nicht gemacht wird. Und was wir machen, ist nicht dagegen was tun, dass der sich an die Schwerlosigkeit anpasst. Weil die Astronauten sagen, das ist toll, das ist super, mir geht's blendend, sondern wir müssten diese ganzen Trainings- und Fitnessmöglichkeiten schaffen, damit die Änderungen nicht zu groß werden, sodass sie dann nicht mehr rückgängig sind. Wir müssen das alles rückgängig machen. Darum kümmert uns auch immer das, wir sagen, die Hauptaufgabe ist jetzt gar nicht die Rehabilitation vom Astronauten, sondern überhaupt die Verhinderung, dass überhaupt solche Effekte eintreten. Und da haben wir auf der Erde, ich sag mal, wir haben geschlafen. Wir haben seit immer, seit es Menschen gibt, haben wir auch Patienten. Und wir haben nie uns darauf konzentriert, dass wir sagen, ok, wenn jemand im Bett liegen muss, gucken wir doch gleichzeitig, dass wir verhindern, dass er negative Effekte davon hat. Wir machen halt die Rehabilitation. Aber wir nehmen es als gottgegeben hin erstmal, dass jemand, der im Bett liegt, halt Knochen- und Muskelabbad und jetzt Kreislauf dekonditioniert. Und was wir jetzt machen, ist zu sagen, ok, wie kann man das Zeug aufhalten? Wie kann man das verhindern? Wie kann man sagen, ok, nimm dein Bett und geh nach Hause?
Ist ja auch für die Astronauten, ich meine gut, die sind natürlich da auch sehr drauf gedrillt und wissen das natürlich auch. Aber ich stelle mir vor, dass wenn man jetzt sozusagen trainiert, nur um eine Verschlechterung zu verhindern, ist was anderes als wenn man jetzt hier auf der Erde trainiert, so mit dem Ziel, ich verbessere meinen Zustand.
Das ist so, genau, weil die Astronauten ja sehr gut trainiert ankommen und im Vergleich, also in den Flug reingehen, im Vergleich dann zu sagen, in Schwerlosigkeit nochmal zu trainieren, damit es noch besser wird. Das kann man eigentlich vergessen, zumindest derzeit vergessen, weil wir derzeit die negative Effekte der Schwerlosigkeit bremsen müssen. Und da machen wir sehr viel Arbeit. Wir konzentrieren uns immer mehr darauf, dass wir sagen, okay, wenn man im Bett liegt oder in Schwerlosigkeit, das sind doch lokalisierte Effekte und diese lokalisierten Effekte, denen kann man doch nur mit richtigem Training entgegentreten, eben nicht mit Tabletten und so weiter, sondern nur mit dem richtigen Training. Und deshalb ist derzeit gesagt, okay, es ist ja doch die Beschleunigung, die hier fehlt. Wir müssen doch in das Training eine Beschleunigung reintun. Und deshalb wird derzeit weltweit geforscht, ob man mit kleinen Centrifugen, die man auch in eine Raumstation reintut, wo man die Astronauten auf eine Centrifuge dreht und damit die Beschleunigung wieder herstellt, ob man da das Training optimieren kann. Eine Centrifuge bedeutet, der Astronaut wird belastet wie auf der Erde. Nur kann man die Centrifuge schneller drehen. Man kann das auch so machen, dass wir an den Beinen zwei- bis dreimal die Erdbeschleunigung haben. Und wenn der Astronaut oder die Astronautin dann noch auf der Centrifuge körperlich trainiert, dann sieht es so aus, wir haben natürlich schon erste Ergebnisse, dann sieht es so aus, als ob man das aufhalten könnte. Deshalb ist konkret im Augenblick so, dass die ESA vorbereitet, für möglicherweise 2015 sogar noch eine Centrifuge auf die Raumstation zu bringen. Also nicht nur die ESA, sondern alle Raumfahrtnationen, die in der Raumstation arbeiten, dass wir international eine gemeinsame Centrifuge hochbringen.
Das ist dann so wie bei 2001 sozusagen die Idee der rotierenden Raumstation?
Das wäre das Ideal, aber leider ist das nicht machbar, das ist nicht bezahlbar. Sondern in einem Forschungsmodul, das schon existiert, soll eine kleine Centrifuge mit einem ganz kleinen Radius gemacht werden. Die Astronauten sollen sich sogar selber über eine Art Fahrrad im Kreis drehen.
Da wird man ja nicht verrückt, da drehen die sich ja irre schnell im Kreis.
Nee, zum Glück ist das schon alles getestet, das ist machbar.
Was für eine Drehungszahl wäre das?
Ich glaube, das war irgendwas von pro Sekunde, oder alle zwei Sekunden einmal, irgendwas in der Gegend.
Alle zwei Sekunden einmal?
Das Wichtige ist, ob es einem da schlecht wird, aber das sieht so aus, als ob das ganz gut funktionieren würde, weil der Kopf dann im Zentrum ist. Der Kopf bleibt noch weitgehend schwerlos. Und es gibt im menschlichen Körper einen Schwerkraftgradienten, einen Beschleunigungsgradienten. Aber da wir ja genau auf der Erde auch die meiste Belastung in der unteren Körperhälfte haben, ist es genau das Richtige, einen Gradienten zu haben.
Was heißt das genau an Gradienten?
Also wenn man sich mit dem Kopf im Zentrum dreht, wenn man sich dreht, dann ist der Kopf nicht beschleunigt. Alles was 10 cm weg ist, ist ein bisschen beschleunigt. Alles was 30 cm ist, ist mehr beschleunigt. Alles was 1 m weg ist, ist viel mehr beschleunigt. Immer wenn man im Radius nach außen geht, dreht es. Alles was außen ist, wird ganz viel beschleunigt. Was innen ist, ist immer weniger. Das nennt man dann einen Beschleunigungsgradient.
Ach so, also so eine logarithmische Kurve.
Das steigt dann immer mehr an.
Verstehe. Es gibt ja nun einige Astronauten, die doch signifikante Zeit im Weltraum verbracht haben. Ich glaube, der Rekord liegt so bei über einem Jahr, 437 Tage oder so was. Das ist ja eine Menge Zeit, wenn man jetzt so unter dem Gesichtspunkt betrachtet, dass nach wenigen Tagen erste Veränderungen zu merken sind bei den Muskeln und nach nur einem Monat auch schon in den Knochen. Wie sind die denn wieder zurückgekommen? In welchem Zustand?
Das ist eine ganz wichtige Frage. Die Antwort heißt, das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Das hängt im Wesentlichen ab von der Motivation, das Astronauten zu trainieren. Der Herr Polyakov, der 430 Tage da oben war, der ist ein Mediziner, ich kenne ihn auch ganz gut, ein Kollege, der selber über die Thematik forscht. Der wollte beweisen, dass es möglich ist, mit Training so lange da oben zu bleiben. Er hat bewiesen, wenn man hoch motiviert ist und sehr viel trainiert, dann kommt man in relativ gutem Zustand zurück.
Was heißt das, relativ guter Zustand?
Der Knochenabbau war relativ, ich weiß jetzt nicht die Prozentzahlen, der Knochenabbau war relativ gering. Er war wenig als kreislaufinstabil. Die Muskeln haben noch ganz gut funktioniert. Er war relativ fit und musste auch nicht so intensiv Rehabilitation machen. Ein bisschen aber schon. Natürlich. Es gibt aber Astronauten, die sind schon nach zwei Monaten mit dem Knochen und den Muskeln ziemlich weit abgesunken. Und wenn man dann guckt, ist es doch in der Regel so, dass jemand, der nicht mit voller Intensität trainiert, dann auch nicht die Effekte des intensiven Trainings hat. Das ist ja irgendwo logisch. Und deshalb sagen wir, es ist auch so, wir haben jetzt große Statistiken. Es gibt auf der Raumstation Trainingsmöglichkeiten. Da gibt es einen Laufband, es gibt einen Fahrradergometer. Und so ein Widerstands-Traininggerät, das muss man sich so endlich vorstellen. Wir gewichtheben, das sind die drei wichtigsten Trainingsgeräte. Es gibt jetzt Statistiken, wo man es auf der Raumstation sieht, die sollen eigentlich jeden Tag, also zwei Stunden trainieren. Und dann mit Vorbereitung und Nachbereitung, zweieinhalb Stunden dauert das. Jetzt können Sie sich vorstellen, nicht jeder trainiert mit höchster Begeisterung und höchstem Einsatz jeden Tag zweieinhalb Stunden.
Da ist man mal im Weltraum und dann muss man die ganze Zeit Fahrrad fahren.
Ja, und deshalb sagen wir, die hohe Motivation ist eigentlich das Wichtige derzeit. Und wir können nicht jedem vorschreiben, dass er hoch motiviert ist. Dann haben die auch sehr viel zu arbeiten. Wenn wir Statistiken sehen, die die Russen gemacht haben, dann sehen wir die Statistiken, dass die nur 40 Prozent der Zeit trainieren und mit 40 Prozent Motivation im Durchschnitt. Und dass das ein großer Unterschied ist. Und die kommen dann wieder unterschiedlich runter. Der eine oder die eine mit weniger Negativeffekten, der andere mit mehr. Das bedeutet für uns Mediziner, wir müssen auch gucken, dass die Trainingsgeräte Spaß machen. Und wir müssen vor allem gucken, dass wir Trainingsgeräte haben, wo es egal ist, ob die jetzt hochmotiviert sind oder nicht so hochmotiviert. Und deshalb gefällt uns die 10. Fuge so. Weil ab der 10. Fuge, wenn wir da rumgedreht werden, da muss man seine Muskel anspannen. Da werden die Knochen nach außen gedrückt. Und man muss einfach was dagegen tun. Und kann trotzdem, was weiß ich, mit dem Kopfhörer Musik hören. Oder auf dem Videobildschirm was anders anschauen. D.h. die Motivation, diese Leistung zu bringen, muss bei einer 10. Fuge nicht so sehr hoch sein. Deshalb sagen wir, wahrscheinlich wird es in Zukunft eine Kombination zwischen Fitnessgerät und 10. Fuge sein. Idealerweise möglichst alles in einem. Dass man während der 10. Fugation auch nach Fahrrad fährt. Was die jetzt sowieso dann machen müssen, wenn sie sich selber rumzentrifugieren müssen.
Hat man es jetzt schon am Computerspielen probiert? Ich würde da oben hängen und müsste jetzt Fahrrad treten. Dann wäre es natürlich viel toller, wenn ich einen Bildschirm vor mir habe, wo ich mit dem Fahrrad ein Computerspiel spiele. Wo ich mich in den Raumstation eigenen Highscore-Listen eintragen kann. Das sozusagen als spielerische Herausforderung.
Das ist eine sehr moderne Meinung von Ihnen. Genau darauf wird es rauslaufen. Wir sind selber derzeit am Bauen einer neuen Forschungsanlage. Die Kombination zwischen Motivation über irgendwelche Videospiele, über virtuelle Realität und dem, was man mit der Fitness macht, wird eine der wichtigen Herausforderungen sein. Das ist natürlich was für alle Fitnessstudios.
Das ist ja auch einmalig. Da ist man in einer Raumstation und kann dann ein Videospiel spielen, wo man irgendwelche Aliens im Weltraum abschießen muss.
Ja, man kann da die Fantasie, da kann man da freien Lauf geben.
Wenn der Herr Paul-Jakob so ein gutes Beispiel dafür gewesen ist, wie man gut überleben kann, was sind denn so die Negativbeispiele? Also wie schlecht ist es den Astronauten schon gegangen, nachdem sie längere Zeit da waren und vielleicht nicht so gut sich nicht in die Highscore-Liste haben eintragen können?
Also es gibt schon viele hundert Astronauten, die geflogen sind. Astronauten sind Menschen und Menschen werden auch krank. Und das heißt, es ist schon sehr, sehr vieles passiert. Also einmal zum Beispiel war allerdings noch ein Feuer. Astronaut hat einen riesen Stress, tagelang nicht geschlafen, musste Raumstationen sicherstellen und hat dann eine Herzrhythmusstörung gekriegt. Und ich glaube, 14 Schläge hat das Herz ausgesetzt. Der war also kurz vorm plötzlichen Herztod. Zum Glück hat dann das Herz wieder weitergeschlagen. Aber so ist natürlich was Massives. Es ist schon mal ein Nierenstein geboren worden. Astronauten sind ja im höheren Risiko, Nierensteine zu kriegen als wir hier unten.
Warum?
Weil eben der Knochenabbau hat. Und wenn der Knochenabbau hat, dann wird Kalzium frei. Und das Kalzium wird dann über die Niere ausgeschieden. Und wenn Kalzium sich mit Phosphat zusammentut, zum Beispiel, oder mit Oxalat oder mit anderen Substanzen, dann bilden sich da schöne Kongremente. Wenn die größer werden, nennt man das einen Stein. Und die tun heftig weh. Also Nierensteine gab es schon, es gab nach Raumflugmissionen. Bei zwei Astronauten ein Herzinfarkt. Das heißt, sowas hätte ja auch in der Mission passieren können. Es gab alle möglichen Sorten von Infektionen, Pilzinfektionen, es gibt immer wieder Augenverletzungen bei Astronauten, weil wenn man was verliert, kann es nur ein Tropfen Flüssigkeit sein, ein Tropfen von irgendeiner Schmiere, von irgendwas, dann fällt das ja nicht runter, sondern das schwebt. Und der Astronaut, der fliegt da nicht mit der Schutzbrille durch die Gegend, sondern kann dann sowas direkt umgeschützt in die Augen kriegen. Deshalb sind die Augenverletzungen relativ häufig leider. Und sonst, also alles irgendwo, was man sich so denken kann. Es gab auch schon Depressionen oder psychische Probleme.
Aber jetzt vielleicht noch mal um dieses Beispiel mit dem Poiakopf einzugehen, der so viel trainiert hat. Was ist denn bei denen, die jetzt weniger trainieren, in welchem Zustand kommen die denn zurück? Also jetzt rein von der Verfassung der Muskeln und Knochen.
Ja, zum Glück ist da noch kein irreversibler Schaden passiert. Da ist dann die Knochenmasse nach sechs Monaten nicht um... also an entscheidenden Knochenstellen ist dann nicht um vier Prozent geringer, sondern um 23 Prozent geringer. Also massiv runtergegangene Knochen, Knochendicke und Knochenfunktion. Oder Muskulatur auf die Hälfte runtergeschrumpft. Oder die Kraft noch weniger als auf die Hälfte. Bei etlichen Muskelgruppen, das kommt schon vor.
Was sind da so die Astronauten, die muss man dann irgendwie aus der Kapsel ziehen und erst mal hinlegen und die können gar nicht laufen?
Das ist sowieso so, dass aus der Seuskapsel, dass die rausgehoben werden, dass die da gar nicht selber gehen dürfen, weil da die Presse dann dabei ist, damit die nicht dann umfallen. Das heißt, die müssen sich tragen lassen. Die werden dann bei den Russen in so ein Zelt getan und da sind da gleich die Mediziner und da werden sie dann hochgepöpelt, kriegen was zu trinken. Die Russen rauchen eine kleine Zigarette, weil sie auf der Raumstation sind.
Aber weil jetzt der Poyer-Kopf dann in so einem guten Zustand, dass er dann auch gleich hätte, einfach wieder laufen können.
Da müsste ich jetzt auch spekulieren. Ich war nicht dabei. Da müsste ich jetzt auch spekulieren, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich dachte, das wäre vielleicht so allgemein bekannt. Das heißt, Krankwerden ist durchaus ein Thema und findet auch statt. Hat sich das denn so verbessert, diese Situation? Oder ist das so eine Front, wo man immer noch zu kämpfen hat? Ist der Zustand der Astronauten in der ISS durchschnittlich jetzt besser, als das so in den Anfangstagen der Raumfahrt war?
Das hängt eigentlich jetzt eher davon ab, dass die mit dem Shuttle ja nur Kurzzeitflüge waren. Das waren Flüge von einer bis zwei Wochen. Da gab es dann die Kurzzeitproblematik. Da mussten die auch nicht groß trainieren. Weil wenn der Knochen so ein bisschen runtergeht nach zwei Wochen, ist es egal. Oder die Muskulatur ist ein bisschen weniger. Das Training ist gar nicht so wichtig. Am Anfang, früher gab es deshalb hauptsächlich die Probleme mit der Übelkeit. Wenn man zwei Wochen da oben ist und davon drei bis fünf Tage ist einem schlecht, dann ist das fast die Hälfte. Jetzt ist die Übelkeit eigentlich kein großes Thema mehr, obwohl es immer noch gleich häufig ist, weil die Leute die ersten drei Tage das Problem haben. Aber dann sind sie ein halbes Jahr da oben. Dann sind sie ein halbes Jahr gesund. Übelkeit, dann Schlafen, die am Anfang, wenn man von der Schwierlosigkeit überwacht, überrascht wird, dann schläft man anders. Das heißt, man schläft erst mal schlecht. Wenn man gestresst ist, alles neu, alles toll, dann schläft jeder schlecht. Das heißt, es gab am Anfang viele, die dann irgendwelche Schlafhilfsmittel genommen haben. Jetzt, wenn sie bei längerer Schwierlosigkeit, die gewöhnen sich halt dran, brauchen sie weniger davon, dann gab es sehr viele Probleme mit Schmerzen in der Kurzzeitraumfahrt. Die gibt es heute auch noch, aber das ist auch wieder so. In den ersten Wochen haben etliche Astronauten Rückenschmerzen. In Schwierlosigkeit wird die Wirbelsäule nicht mehr zusammengequetscht, kann sich ausdehnen. Die Bandscheiben lagern dann so Flüssigkeit ein. Dann wird der typische Astronaut mindestens 5 cm länger. Im Rahmen dieser Dehnung der Wirbelsäule verkrampfen sich die Haltemuskeln. Dann kriegt man Rückenschmerzen.
Ist das dann aber vielleicht langfristig gut für den Rücken, dass man sich einmal hat strecken können?
Das hat jetzt noch keiner untersucht. Hinterher wird es wieder anders. Aber das medizinische Problem ist, dass dann 10-15% von Astronauten zum Teil heftige Rückenschmerzen kriegen, die dann über Wochen anhalten und dann auch mit Tabletten therapiert werden müssen. Das ist auch etwas, was sich jetzt in der Priorität ein bisschen verlagert, weil die Missionen so lang werden. Ansonsten diese Augenverletzungen, das habe ich schon gesagt, und auf der Meerstation waren es dann zum Teil oberflächliche Pilzinfektionen, weil so ein Lebenserhaltungssystem natürlich auch für Mikroorganismen eine Spielwiese ist. So eine Raumstation ist eine hochtechnische Anlage. Da ist natürlich auch Luftfeuchtigkeit, Wärme. Und hinter den Panels, wie wir sie nennen, hinter der Wand, ist in der Regel Elektronik und Technik. Und es ist absolut unmöglich, da dauernd zu putzen. Und deshalb wachsen dann unter Umständen Filme von Mikroorganismen und dann gibt es Pilze. Und man kann sich dann Hautpilze holen.
Man kann auch nicht mal eben desinfizieren und reinsprühen, weil das ist auch gleich...
Es ist zur Zeit seit mehreren Jahren ein Riesenthema, welche antimikrobiellen Oberflächen nimmt man? Also dass man gleich die Oberflächen so mit... Es gibt Silberlegierungen und so. Welche antimikrobiellen Oberflächen nimmt man, damit man dieses Problem in den Griff kriegt?
Verstehe, dass ich das gar nicht erst ansiedeln kann, weil die entsprechenden Metalle... Geht es da nur um Metalle oder ist es auch andere?
Ich bin da kein Spezialist, da könnte ich jetzt spekulieren. Und ansonsten haben wir natürlich noch das Problem, ein Problem, das man lange nicht erkannt hatte. In so einer Umgebung ist es laut, weil da lauter Maschinen drin sind. Und deshalb ist es so, dass wir inzwischen leider wissen, dass von den Leuten, die auf der Meerstation waren, dass von denen viele eine verfrühte Schwerhörigkeit gekriegt haben. Und deshalb ist es jetzt so, dass es natürlich große Programme gibt, dass die Astronauten auch immer so einen Ohrstöpsel tragen, damit sie einen Hörschutz tragen, damit sie die Problematik nicht kriegen.
Auf der ISS ist es aber nicht so laut, wie es auf der Meer war.
Es ist nicht so laut, aber es ist auch laut, in verschiedenen Modulen verschieden laut. Und vor allem sind die Maschinen ja 24 Stunden an. 24 Stunden am Tag. Also schon allein nachts den Gehörschutz tragen, ist schon etwas, was die mögliche Schädigung auf um ein Drittel reduziert. Da wird derzeit viel gemacht. Früher hat man das nicht so beachtet. Und schon ist es passiert. Ansonsten gibt es halt die normalen Probleme, Unfälle. Wir hoffen natürlich immer, dass es nicht größere Unfälle gibt. Aber kann natürlich alles auftreten.
Werden denn die Astronauten auch im Schlaf die ganze Zeit medizinisch überwacht?
Nein, es gibt keine Dauerüberwachung. Auch, dass man sagt, die werden dauernd telemedizinisch überwacht, ist eigentlich nicht so. Es sind ja lauter gesunde Leute erstmal. Die werden dann diagnostiziert, wenn man irgendwie eine Krankheit vermutet. Sonst gibt es einmal im Monat einen kleinen Checkup. Aber die werden nicht nachts mit irgendwas überwacht. Es sei denn, sie nehmen an einer wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung teil. Dann kann natürlich sein, dass sie dann 20 Elektroden irgendwo dran haben.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, die Schlafforscher dürften sich doch auch extrem dafür interessieren.
Die Schlafforschung ist eine ganz wichtige Forschung, weil die Schlafstruktur auch geändert ist in Schwerelosigkeit, ist also akademisch auch interessant. Und ist operationell wichtig, weil nur wenn man gut schläft, ist man am nächsten Tag fit. Die Schlafqualität ist eigentlich das Wichtigste für die Fitness der Astronauten. Also auch für die psychische und für die physische. Und deshalb wird da auch viel geforscht.
Träumt man denn da anders?
Da habe ich jetzt noch keinen gefragt. Oder keinen gefragt. Das weiß ich nicht. Ein Problem haben wir noch gar nicht besprochen, das ist die Strahlung. In 400 Kilometer Höhe hat man so Pi mal Fensterkreuz mindestens das 200-fache der Strahlung, der wir hier auf der Erde unten ausgesetzt sind. Und deshalb müssen wir die Astronauten, müssen wir zum einen immer betreuen damit, dass wir die Strahlung messen, der die ausgesetzt sind. Und wenn die ein gewisses Limit erreicht haben, die Astronauten, dann dürfen die auch nicht mehr fliegen. Das ist also ein wirkliches Tauglichkeitskriterium. Leider ist es so, dass die Strahlungsintensität nicht vorhersagebar ist und versagbar ist. Und dass sie ganz groß schwanken kann. Die hängt von ganz vielen Parametern ab. Das ist auch wirklich kompliziert. Und es ist auch noch so, dass vieles von der Strahlung, die es da oben gibt, hier unten auf der Erde gar nicht gibt. Das heißt, wir kennen die Gefährdung zum Teil von einzelnen Strahlenarten gar nicht. Zum Beispiel von ganz schweren, hochenergetischen Ionen. Eisen, da fliegen richtig schwere Eisen-Ionen rum. Deren Gefährdung kennen wir eigentlich nicht so richtig.
Weil die machen es gar nicht bis zur Erde.
Die machen nicht bis zur Erde. Und die werden auf der Erde, können die so hochenergetisch gar nicht hergestellt werden in einem Beschleuniger.
Das heißt, man kann es auch nicht simulieren.
Wir können es gar nicht messen. Das heißt, die Strahlendosimetrie und Strahlenspyologie ist ein wahnsinnig wichtiges Gebiet für die Betreuung der Astronauten. Vor allem, wenn man sagt, die sollen mal irgendwann länger entweder auf Raumstationen ein paar Jahre bleiben oder zum Mars fliegen, dann braucht man die Strahlendosimetrie. Da muss man gucken, was macht man vom Strahlenschutz her. Wie fährt man die körpereigenen Strahlenschutzmechanismen hoch? Wir haben ja so einzelne Moleküle, die tun nichts anderes als Strahlenschäden reparieren, die Schutzmechanismen. Und die muss man hochfahren. Bevor man die hochfahren kann, muss man die erst verstehen. Muss sie erst erforschen.
Wenn man jetzt so ganz naiv betrachtet, kann man sagen, naja wieso, man ist doch da oben ganz gut gekapselt. Man hat so viel Metall um sich drum herum. Schummt das nicht so das Allermeiste schon ab?
Zum Teil hat man recht, die Strahlung, die relativ wenig energetisch ist, die wird dann, also alles, was auf der Haut, wenn sie auf der Haut aufprallt, dann schon zerfällt. Das wird wunderschön durch die Raumstation abge... Also UV-Strahlung zum Beispiel. Genau, das wird alles abgefangen. Deshalb ist die Belastung auch von Astronauten an der Körperoberfläche innerhalb der Raumstation wesentlich weniger, als wenn sie raussteigen. Dummerweise sind das die Strahlen, die eigentlich gefährlich sind, nämlich die hochenergetischen. Die lassen sich durch so eine Raumschiffwand gar nicht ärgern, sondern die fliegen da einfach durch, weil die so hochenergetisch sind. Und zum Teil, und zum Teil ist es noch blöder, die werden dann da etwas abgebremst und im Abbremsen geben die jede Menge von Sekundärstrahlen ab, sodass es dann ganze Strahlenschauer gibt, die auf den Astronauten einprasseln. Und dummerweise sind dann die niederenergetischeren Strahlen gefährlicher als die hochenergetischen.
Das heißt, genau diese Abfallprodukte beim Auftreffen setzen sich dann...
Die sind dann schädigender als der ursprüngliche Strahl. Und deshalb ist man leider im Raumschiff eben vor den bösen Wirkungen der Strahlen nicht geschützt.
Gibt es denn Detektoren, um überhaupt diese Strahlung zu messen? Ist das überhaupt möglich, alle diese Strahlentypen, die man da befürchtet?
Es gibt Detektoren, um das zu messen. Es gibt eine weltweite Community. Unser Institut ist so mit das führende Institut auf dem Gebiet. Wir haben auf der Raumstation seit 2003 ein menschliches Phantom, das ist also ein echtes menschliches Skelett, eingegossen in so ein Plastik, ist außen drüber. Innen ist ein echtes menschliches Skelett. Wir fliegen da seit 2003 ein Skelett da oben.
Ein Skelett auf der Raumstation.
Und da sind innendrin mehrere tausend Strahlendetektoren, damit man genau die verschiedenen Arten von Strahlen messen kann. Und nicht nur theoretisch, wie würden die jetzt zerfallen, oder wie würden die jetzt im Körper des Menschen ankommen, sondern praktisch gemessen. Und deshalb brauchen wir auch das echte Skelett, damit wir wissen, wenn die Strahlen sich an der Rippe, wenn der aufprallt und dann Sekundärstrahl gibt, was sind das für Sekundärstrahlen? Und was ist echt die Belastung der Leber, der Milz, der Geschlechtsorgane, der Lunge im menschlichen Körper?
Woran ist dieses Skelett eingefasst?
Das ist so ein Kunststoff.
Ist der so beschaffen, dass er so ähnlich ist wie der normale Körper?
Ja, die Dichte ist so wie von menschlichem Gewebe. Mit Ausnahme der Knochen, da braucht man leider die Echtknochen. Und innen rein tut man diese vielen Strahlendosimeter und kann dann an jeder Stelle des menschlichen Körpers messen, wie viel kriegt man da ab. Und deshalb wissen wir auch, das haben wir vorher eigentlich nicht so vorher gesehen, haben die Messungen halt dann gezeigt, dass das, was an der Haut ankommt und dass das massiv sich ändert, ob der Astronaut jetzt draußen ist oder innen drin, aber was innen ankommt, da ist kein großer Unterschied mehr zwischen außen in der Weltraumspazierung sein und innen abgeschirmt, im Glauben abgeschirmt durch das Raumschiff, ist der Unterschied nicht mehr sehr groß.
Und was sind das jetzt so für Strahlentypen, die jetzt im Wesentlichen da ihr Unwesen treiben? Also was hat das vor allem für Auswirkungen?
Also Strahlentypen, man muss wissen, jeder Stern ist ein Fusionsreaktor. Und es gibt dann auch die Sternexplosionen, die Supernovae. Das heißt, wir haben das Weltall voll von Milliarden und Milliarden und Milliarden von solchen Quellen von Strahlen. Das bedeutet jede Art von Strahlung, alles, was sich vorstellen kann.
Jede erdenkliche Früge.
Diese Sterne können viel mehr als die menschlichen Atomreaktoren. Und das fliegt dann im Vakuum da rum, das Zeug. Wir haben Angst vor zwei, hauptsächlich vor zwei Dingen. Das eine sind die hochenergetischen Protonen, hochenergetische Protonen und die hochenergetischen Schwerenionen. Alles andere mögen wir natürlich auch nicht. Aber das sind die zwei Sachen, die richtig die Sorgen machen.
Und eben wegen dieses Effektes, das wenn die auf die Raumstation aufschlagen, dass sie sich dann...
Die gehen da einfach durch die Wand und verteilen sich. Und dann ist die sekundär und terziär Strahlen, die sind dann noch eher gefährlicher.
Und was weiß man dann darüber, was es bewirkt? Also was ist die Auswirkung davon?
Ja, Strahlung, wir wissen, macht Krebs, kann Krebs machen und kann genotoxisch sein. Das heißt, dann kann sie Erbmaterial schädigen. Das heißt, wenn ein Astronaut, der jetzt so einen Schaden haben würde, dann Kinder kriegt, dann kann es dann Erbschaden geben. Das sind die zwei Dinge. Und natürlich kann Strahlung auch direkt schädigen und Strahlenkrankheit machen. Also theoretisch könnte es auch mal sein, auf dem Weg zum Mars, wenn eine wahnsinnige Sonneneruption passiert, dass auf einen Schlag so viel Strahlung da freigesetzt wird, dass Astronauten sogar direkt strahlenkrank werden. Das ist auch möglich. Also wenn man die Vergangenheit extrapoliert, dann ist das extremst unwahrscheinlich. Aber auch extremst unwahrscheinliche Sachen können auch mal passieren. Deshalb ist der Strahlenschutz für den Flug zum Mars zum Beispiel oder für eine Mondstation ist eigentlich unser größtes ungelöstes Problem. Weil wir die Wand nicht so dick machen können auf der einen Seite und zum anderen haben wir die körpereigenen Schutzmechanismen auch noch nicht so im Griff. Also man sagt jetzt ja, man muss dann auf so einen Flug irgendwo ein Shelter machen, wo sich alle Astronauten dann zusammen quetschen, wo dann doch eine relativ dicke Wand ist oder wo ganz viel, ganz dick Wasser, ein viel Meter Wasser außen rum ist. Aber es ist noch alles ungelöst.
Weltraum ist kein Ponyhof.
Richtig.
Da ist richtig was los. Aber wenn man sich jetzt so mit der ganzen medizinischen Situation der Erde und der Menschen im Weltall beschäftigt, inwiefern fällt denn da jetzt auch so dieser Forschungsbereich Leben auf anderen Planeten mit rein? Spielt das überhaupt eine Rolle?
Das spielt eine Rolle. Wir arbeiten auch in unserem Institut an dieser Thematik. Es gibt da zwei Aspekte. Der eine Aspekt ist, wenn wir als Raketen irgendwo los schicken oder auf dem Mars mit Rovern rumfahren, dann sollten wir nicht auf dem Mars die Mikroorganismen einschleppen, die vielleicht bisher noch gar nicht da gewesen sind. Das heißt, oder auf irgendwelchen anderen Himmelskörpern.
Das extraterrestische Leben wurde deshalb nicht entdeckt, weil man es ausgerottet hat in dem Moment, als man danach geschaut hat.
Wir sollen nicht Mikroorganismen selber mit den Raketen mitfliegen lassen oder mit dem Mars-Rovern, die dann irgendwo ausgesetzt werden. 20 Jahre später finden wir das gleiche Leben wieder und sagen, oh, das ist das gleiche wie uns. Verstehe.
Das ist ja alles wie bei uns.
Weil es gibt ja auch einen Jupiter-Mond, der gefroren ist. Wenn wir da Mikroorganismen reintun, dann kann das da ja konserviert werden. Oder was weiß ich, kalte Oberflächen. Das nennt man Planetary Protection. Damit man das Ausland der halben Erde vor unserem Leben schützt. Da ist es so, dass wir inzwischen wissen, dass wir mit jeder Rakete, die irgendwo landet, oder mit allem, was wir los schicken, Mikroorganismen, los schicken. Und zwar jede Menge. Die Raketen werden zwar in Satelliten, in Reinträumen zusammengebaut. Aber da werden viele Mikroorganismen, die fühlen sich sogar wohl in Reinträumen. Also wir wissen das, dass wir das los schicken. Deshalb gibt es jetzt auch eine große Forschungsrichtung, die sagt, okay, was halten Mikroorganismen eigentlich aus? Vom Vakuum, Weltraumvakuum, die Strahlung, das UVC-Licht und so. Und da ist es auch so, dass viele Mikroorganismen oder deren Sporen, vielleicht die Mikroorganismen nicht selber, aber deren Sporen, dass die zum Teil so viel aushalten, dass man sich nur wundern kann. Und dass es deshalb durchaus möglich ist, dass sich Leben von Planet zu Planet auch weiter propagiert. Es ist sogar möglich, wenn irgendwo auch auf der Erde, wenn da ein großer Komet einschlägt. Und mit so einer Geschwindigkeit, dass aus der Erdumlaufbahn Erdmaterial wieder rausgeschleudert wird, solange das nicht an der Oberfläche ist und solange das nicht dem UVC ausgesetzt wird, wissen wir, kann dieses Leben über Millionen von Jahren überleben. Und wenn es dann wieder eingefangen wird, wieder landet, nicht verglüht, sondern innen ist noch ein kalter Kern, dann kann das Leben wieder bleiben. Das ist die Möglichkeit, dass sich Leben von einem zum anderen verpflanzt. Und die andere Frage ist, ist auf außerhalb der Erde kann der Leben entstanden sein? Da gibt es natürlich auch eine große Forschungsgemeinde. Das sieht auch so aus, als ob das nicht unwahrscheinlich wäre, sondern umgekehrt. Es muss wahrscheinlich außerhalb der Erde von Leben wimmeln. Und das muss man natürlich nur finden. Man muss da unterscheiden zwischen niedrigen Stufen von Leben und hochentwickelndem Leben, intelligentem Leben. Intelligentes Leben ist etwas, was eher sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass es viel davon gibt. Aber nicht so intelligentes, niederes Leben müsste es eigentlich relativ viel geben. Und deshalb sind so viele interessiert, ob es auf dem Mars Leben gegeben hat oder gibt. Und bei Mars ist es so, dass in der Zeit, in der auf der Erde das Leben entstanden ist, nach allem, was wir wissen, dass in der Zeit, in der wir bei uns das Leben entstanden ist, dass auf dem Mars die Bedingungen da praktisch identisch waren.
Also Wasser.
Da gab es Wasser, da gab es Vulkane, da gab es auch die Meteoriten, da gab es eine Atmosphäre. Die Atmosphäre war sogar ähnlich wie bei uns auf der Erde. Also alles war ziemlich ähnlich. Das war unser Nachbarplanet quasi mit ähnlichen Bedingungen. Bei uns ist Leben entstanden. Und wenn bei uns ist Leben entstanden, ist die Frage, warum ist da nicht auch Leben entstanden? Man kann ja jetzt umgekehrt spekulieren und sagen, bisher heißt es die Spekulation, wir sind einfach einzigartig. Kann aber auch die Spekulation heißen, wir sind normal. Das ist auch eine Spekulation. Das heißt, viele Leute sagen, Mars könnte es schon sein, dass da Leben gegeben hat. Viele gehen weiter und sagen, wenn es gegeben hat, dann gibt es es auch noch. Aber nicht auf der Oberfläche.
Tief unten eingegraben.
Nicht in zwei Metern, sondern ganz tief unten.
Und wartet darauf, dass es irgendwann wieder verfreit wird.
Genau. Das sind grundsätzliche Fragen. Aber grundsätzliche Fragen über unser Verständnis im All.
Und das ist alles im Mittelpunkt der Forschung der Weltraummedizin?
Die Astrobiologie ist ein anderes Themengebiet. Es ist aber ein Themengebiet, das sich mit Leben befasst. Wir haben in unserem Institut auch das heißt Luft- und Raumfahrtmedizin. Wir machen ja auch biologische Forschung an Pflanzen zum Beispiel oder an kleinen Mikroorganismen. Das ist auch jetzt nicht unbedingt Raumfahrtmedizin. Wir haben bei uns ein Institut, das im DLR lebenswissenschaftliche Fragen beantwortet. Da der Schwerpunkt aber die Luft- und Raumfahrtmedizin ist, ist das der Name des Instituts.
Das haben wir am Anfang ja betont, es geht hier ums Forschen. Wir kommen ja selber auch aus diesem Umfeld von vornherein. Wie groß ist denn jetzt der Rückfluss hier aus dem Institut in die Gemeinde? Ist man gut vernetzt? Auch wenn es nur so wenige Institute gibt mit einer ähnlichen Spezialisierung. Aber es gibt ja auch viele andere Institute, die sich auf irgendwas spezialisiert haben.
Es gibt natürlich zum Beispiel in Deutschland viele Forscher, die Weltraumforschung machen. Es gibt in Berlin zum Beispiel ein Konsortium von Wissenschaftlern, die die Berliner Weltraumforschung machen in der Charité. Es ist nicht ein Institut, aber da haben sich Forscher aus verschiedenen Instituten zu einem virtuellen Institut zusammengetan. Die sind sehr aktiv in München, in vielen Städten wird das hier in Deutschland beforscht. Wir selber sind natürlich intensiv vernetzt, sowohl mit Weltraumforschern als auch mit normalen Forschern, die die Möglichkeit, zusätzlich die Schwierlosigkeit nicht haben. Lokal sind wir natürlich in Köln, in der Kölner Uni sehr gut. Wir arbeiten sehr viel zusammen, weil eben die Forschung am Knochen und am Muskel nicht bloß vom Aspekt der Raumfahrt gemacht wird, sondern es ist eine Grundlagenforschung. Oder mit der Orthopädie in Köln. Mit Bonn sind wir vernetzt. Also hier lokal mit der Sporthochschule. Aber weltweit sind wir mit hervorragenden Unis vernetzt. Zum Beispiel unsere Schlafforschung. Da haben wir jetzt gerade ein Abkommen geschlossen mit der Harvard University. Mit dem Schlaflabor in der Harvard University. Weil die mit uns wieder zusammenarbeiten wollen. Die interessieren sich jetzt auch nicht so sehr für den Weltraum, aber für die Schlafforschung. Das sehen die sich. Wir sehen, wie ich schon mehrmals betont habe, eben nicht die Raumfahrtforschung als irgendwas Exklusives, was anders ist als anderes, sondern ist auch eine Möglichkeit, Wissen über das Leben zu erhalten oder über den Menschen zu erhalten.
Wenn jetzt jemand so eine Ausbildung macht im medizinischen Bereich und das mit der Raumfahrt ganz spannend findet, welche Möglichkeit gibt es denn da, sich schon auf dem Ausbildungsweg zu spezialisieren?
In Richtung Raumfahrt. Also ich empfehle immer den Leuten zunächst nicht in der Raumfahrt zu arbeiten, sondern zunächst eine Ausbildung in einer bestimmten Richtung machen. Also wenn es die Medizin ist, in einer medizinischen Richtung, und dann dort zu forschen und dort dann durchaus auch Raumfahrtforschung zu machen. Aber erstmal als Kliniker eine klinische Ausbildung machen oder wer im Labor arbeiten will, eine wissenschaftliche Ausbildung in einem Fachgebiet, in der Medizin, in der Physiologie oder in der Pharmakologie. Und dann kann man von da aus immer noch die Raumfahrt dazunehmen. Aber erstmal muss man grundsätzlich lernen, Fragen zu stellen, zu forschen. Und nicht nur so, nicht sich nur in eine Nische reinbegeben. Weil die Raumfahrt, wenn man sie nur betreibt, ist natürlich im gesamten Feld der Forschung schon eine Nische. Wenn man gleich in eine Nische reingeht, dann kommt man möglicherweise nicht mehr raus. Wenn man aber umgekehrt sagt, ich will erstmal grundsätzlich, wenn mich der Knochen interessiert als Wissenschaftler, über Knochen lernen. Und wenn ich dann die Raumfahrt dazunehm, dann habe ich gewonnen quasi, weil dann weiß ich sehr viel und habe noch eine zusätzliche Möglichkeit, Wissen zu erlangen, was die anderen dann nicht haben. Deshalb empfehle ich nie den Leuten, gleich in die Raumfahrt zu gehen oder zu bleiben. Natürlich haben wir junge Leute, die auch hier sind. Den empfehle ich aber immer. So geht dann aber noch irgendwo allgemeiner hin und kommt dann wieder zur Raumfahrt zurück. Das ist viel besser.
Also wird hier auch in irgendeiner Form ausgebildet?
Wir machen natürlich sehr viel Ausbildung. Von jungen Nachwuchskräften. Wir machen zum einen für Unis oder Fachhochschulen, Hochschulen, mit denen zusammen Masterarbeiten und Bachelorarbeiten. Wir haben ein großes Doktorandenprogramm. Wir haben einen Doktorandenkolleg, das nennt sich Space Life. Da arbeiten in unserem Institut hier 15 Doktoranden und an assoziierten Unis nochmal 7 oder 8, also 22, 23 Doktoranden, die eine strukturierte Doktorandenausbildung kriegen, die also da forschen lernen, publizieren lernen. Die müssen dann im Rahmen der Arbeit eine Publikation schreiben oder zwei und dann sogenannte Soft-Skills-Kurse kriegen, also wie benehm ich mich in der wissenschaftlichen Welt oder wie halte ich Vorträge, oder wie bewerbe ich mich, wie schaue ich, dass ich dann unterkomme, was sollte ich am besten nicht tun und so. Ja, das ist was sehr Attraktives. Da haben wir gerade eine Runde fast durch und wir suchen im nächsten Jahr die nächste Runde. Also wenn von ihren Zuhörern, welche Doktorarbeit in der Raumfahrt, Lebenswissenschaft in der Raumfahrt machen wollen, gibt es bald eine Ausschreibung.
Herr Gerzer, ich denke, wir haben es beisammen. Ein Ausflug in die Raumfahrt, Medizin und in die Astrobiologie. Ich bin hier weitergekommen als ich dachte. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.